In school, I learned the trigonometric functions
kinda like this. You have a right angled triangle,
an angle typically called theta here,
mathematicians love greek letters, and you
label the sides, opposite, adjacent, hypotenuse.
Then you have the famous formulas, sine equals
opposite over hypotenuse, cosine equals adjacent
over hypotenuse, and tan = opposite over adjacent.
In 20 years of development, even in graphics
work, I think for me this triangle has come
in handy close to zero times, so instead, another
way of visualising this is to start with a circle,
and to simplify things further we use
one with a radius of exactly 1. That is,
any point that lies here on the circle, is
at a distance of exactly 1 from the centre.
Typically, this angle here between our vector
and the x axis, theta, is expressed in degrees
ranging from 0 to 360, but apparently this
is some arbitrary system leftover from, well
they’re not quite sure, but if you think about
the circumference of a circle, that’s defined
by 2xPIxR, with a radius of 1, that boils down to
just 2xPI, so instead of degrees, if we started
at the x axis here, and moved 1 unit of distance
along the circle, we could invent new unit for
angles, called a radian, so now we express angles
in terms of distance along the outside of the
circle, and thus a circle is 2 PI radians, instead
of 360 degrees, and that's how radians are made.
Now, given this point here on the circle, it
forms an angle theta, and since the radius of
this circle is 1, the hypotenuse is 1, so sin
is just this distance here along the vertical,
and that means cosine is just this
distance here along the horizontal,
and tan, well if you extend a line here from x
= 1 upwards, and you extend the vector forming
your hypotenuse out this way, where they
2 meet, tan gives you this distance here,
the distance from their intersection down to
the x axis. I never use this, but it’s there.
As you move this point around the circle,
we obviously expect cos theta, sin theta,
and tan theta to change, and
we can graph those changes,
so sin theta oscillates between 1 and
-1 as this vector rotates the circle,
and cos theta oscillates in much the same way,
but just slightly offset from sin of theta.
Tan is interesting, because at PI/2 and -PI/2,
you can see that tan theta is undefined,
hopefully now seeing this in
action an what tan really is,
the graph of tan theta makes more sense,
why it kinda freaks out at certain values.
This is where it gets a little
interesting. If we call this vector A,
we know cos theta is just the x component
of this vector here on the unit circle.
Or, you could say this a different way, a slightly
longer way of saying it is in terms of
this vector A, it is a.x * 1 + a.y * 0
Or again, now we can say it
in terms of both A and B,
where you know the B vector
is just the x axis, or (1, 0)
Sso it’s a.x * b.x + a.y * b.y
Which is, now defined in a more mathematical
way, it has a name, it’s the dot product. So,
the dot product of a and b = cos theta, which is
just this horizontal distance here, if a & b are
unit vectors, the more general equation you were
taught in school was a.b = ||a|| ||b|| cos theta.
So now it might make more intuitive sense
then for why, given any 2 unit vectors,
if we take the dot product
between them, you get cos theta,
because if you were to rotate these things
around the circle until we hit the x axis,
and suddenly this is just reduced to
our simple distance along the x axis
Actual real proofs exist,
with real math and everything,
this isn't one of them, just a
nice way of visualising things.
But this is also why the dot product is
used to get the scalar projection of 1
vector onto another, because
that’s all this distance is.
So then, how are these functions
implemented? If you have a chunk of
code, when you call your hardware or
library function for stuff like sin,
what kind of math sorcery are they doing? Well,
these tend to be computed in different ways.
Various approximations have existed
for ages. Back in the 7th century,
the Indian mathematician Bhaskara gave the
following formula, which I’m not going to read,
but it worked really well in the range of [0,
PI], giving an absolute error of less than 0.0016.
In game development, way back in the
day, it was often acceptable to use
something called a lookup table.
By precomputing values and either
finding the closest match or linearly
interpolating between adjacent values,
it was possible to use a relatively small
lookup table to get acceptable results.
A lookup table with 512 entries might
have an error of around 0.000001, or 1e-6,
but getting things super right
in games isn’t usually critical,
nobody’s life is on the line, unless
you’re jigsaw, so for example,
you could use 16 values from 0 to pi/2
and that gives an error of around 0.0014,
but cache misses are slow these days, so
lookup tables aren't used as often anymore
If you were to compute these trig functions
directly, the first thought is a taylor expansion,
and courtesy of wikipedia, they look
like this, which does the job nicely,
but a common complaint with taylor
series is that the error isn’t uniform,
the error scales the further you are from 0.
Better approaches have a general theme. They
combine a whole bunch of ideas. They tend to
do what’s called a range reduction, followed by
an approximation, and then a reconstruction step.
First off, looking at a sin wave,
you clearly don’t need to approximate
from -infinity to infinity, we already
know that it repeats after [0, 2 PI].
From there, you can exploit symmetry,
this half is really the same as this half,
just upside down, and this half of the wave
is really just a mirror of the other side.
So in reality, you only need to
approximate a small portion. So
now you have 4 identical quadrants for
this function, just flipped and reversed.
So given a point in any of these quadrants,
you’d map it to a point in the first. Then,
you may use a polynomial approximation
like the taylor series we just covered,
or something more advanced like minimax, anyway,
you compute your value, then you map it back into
the appropriate quadrant, and voila, you have an
idea of how your hardware computes a sin value.
The sin function on the screen is
running the code you see on the left.
Intel has a paper from like 20 years ago which
details how a lot of their trig functions were
implemented, you can also poke around the gnu
c library and see similar ideas in action,
if you can read the code, it’s
not the easiest to work through.
Robin Green has a nice writeup on their blog
as well, which is linked in the description.
Lastly, this explanation is taken from an
up and coming math course I’m working on.
It’ll be available soon, if you’re interested
in more intuitive explanations of trigonometry,
matrices, and math for game
development, check it out.
Until next time,
Cheers